it was a scandal that walks the entire
car industry and angered the public in
laie 2015 car maker volkswagen admitted
that millions of its diesel vehicles
were equipped with software that could
cheat emissions test other major brands
have since come under scrutiny as well
many asked how could this has gone
undetected in the EU the full out led to
strong calls for an overhaul into type
approval regime that's the current
system of testing and approving cars
compliance with the law but car
manufacturing is the core business for
several member states so agreeing on
exactly how to shake up the industry
hasn't been easy under current rules a
manufacturer can obtain approval for a
vehicle type in one EU country and sell
it across the block without further
tests some say this allows car makers to
shop and choose a country where they can
easily get approval any peace want to
put a stop to such practices a draft law
is being debated the curb cheating they
want strong and clear obligations for
countries to fulfill in controlling the
type approval process they also want
independent easy auditors to check on
whether member states are conducting
visser valence to achieve
you